We are now 7.3 billion
fellow human beings,
on the only place we can live
and in the next twenty five
years, we're going to be
9 billion fellow human beings
with no other place to go.
I went to Egypt.
Right before the landscape
of the Great Pyramids of Giza,
people are fighting for food.
Because they couldn't
afford food anymore,
due to the rising cost of wheat.
They had to get government
subsidized bread.
And every day in thousands of
these kiosks across Egypt,
people are fighting just to
be able to get food.
Something as basic as bread.
I went to Iowa,
to look at the bread basket of
the world, the United States.
This is the Kuntz family, a
fourth generation farmer.
And boy, the commodity prices
are going through the roof.
They're making the money,
They're making a bonanza.
And this family is so engrained,
they become literally,
almost reflected
in their combine.
Become the product that they
grow, product that they reap.
But when commodity prices
start to go through the roof,
because of natural disasters.
Like in this case,
the Mississippi River,
flooding the farmlands
of Iowa.
Commodity prices go
through the roof,
affecting all of us
across the planet.
We also are having another
divergence of food,
out of our stomachs and into
the stomachs of pigs,
and also into the
stomachs of our cars.
Raising again,
the cost of food.
And that has an enormous impact
on the cost of how
we feed ourselves.
We may not notice it
in this country,
but if you live on two dollars
a day, you'll see that it does.
We went to the Amazon.
Brazil wants to become the
next bread basket of the world.
President Dilma as no issues
about cutting down the Amazon.
There's a brilliant statement
in what she said.
"Okay, if you want us
to keep the trees
to produce oxygen, pay us."
Because they want to have
an economic bounty,
because that's what we did
in North America.
That area of all of the midwest
used to be forests and swamps.
And we created it as the world's
largest bread basket.
And other nations want to
do the same thing
We went to India to look at
the Green Revolution.
India in the sixties
was crippled,
and hardly able to feed itself,
coming out into independence.
And in this case,
now they're in a bounty because,
science and technology
came together,
fertilizers and pesticides.
This case a farmer is thrilled.
Look how many people
are riding on the top of
a bounteous harvest.
You'd never see that in America,
code police would
come out and say,
"Too many people
on your tractor."
I think it's beautiful actually.
( audience laughter )
But they, they polluted
their water table system.
And in the Punjab region
of Northwest India,
birth defects and cancer
rates through the roof.
All in order to try to
feed ourselves.
In the Philippines, with the
rising commodity prices,
children want to become
farmers again.
Instead of going to the city in
metro Manila or overseas
to work in houses
in Saudi Arabia
and Hong Kong
as housekeepers.
Why?
Because you can make a
living to be a farmer again.
And here younger
children are learning,
from their grandparents,
how to be farmers again.
So, pretty neat.
And in the Philippines,
is the International Rice
Research Institute
where everyday rice comes in
from all over the world,
and hands deftly sort
each grain of rice
for the strongest grains.
And here's how
it's so important.
When Pol Pot decimated
the agricultural
industry of Cambodia,
all of their rice fields
got destroyed.
And they couldn't grow
rice properly anymore
when they brought in rice from
Thailand and elsewhere.
And IRRI, International Rice
Research Institute,
had a small packet of
seeds in their vault,
and they brought those
seeds back to Cambodia,
and to this day,
the Cambodians are growing
their own indigenous rice again.
All because of these hands,
deftly sorting out the
strongest genes of seed.